my next speaker has been a warrior for
freedom for Israel and for the shared
value systems that Israel and the United
States both enjoy and respect individual
rights equality of rights under the law
Helen fredman is singular another yes
tell please
Applause is another Brave and when I say
Brave what is The Bravery The Bravery is
anyone that takes up this issue is
demonized marginalized rended Radio
Active destroyed your name the one thing
the only thing that in my opinion that
means anything in this world who and
what you are and what you stand for is
destroyed and smeared because you speak
for freedom and this W woman is
unwavering and so I want to thank Helen
for coming from far and and agreeing to
speak to us this afternoon Helen
y it's it's a it's a privilege to be
part of this uh demonstration microne
doesn't
amplify you speak it's
unfortunate that um we have to be here
uh to
castigate uh these people who are
willing to and eager to squel free
speech here in America uh we have to
remind everybody every body this is not
islaman this is America and we enjoy
freedom of speech here and we will speak
out on every subject that we wish and we
will S stand on the streets of America
with our flags and with our banners and
signs and say the
truth now there is a cancer here in this
Society
tragically tragically it is being
promoted by by the leadership in the
country the leadership the White House
President Obama the Pentagon the
Department of Defense are unable to call
a spade a spade they're unable to say
that there is Jihad here in America
they're unable to call the Fort Hood
killing uh what it was is an act of
Islamic terrorism they call it workplace
violence it was November of
2009 when Nal
Hassan yelling Allah
abbar having just gotten off the phone
with his Al Qaeda
friend that Nal his son went and killed
13 Americans and wounded
32 in a very very very clear Act of
Islamic
terrorism it was called workplace
violence the people who were wounded and
the people who were killed are trying to
be awarded of course not the dead but
their representatives the awarded the
Purple Heart for their Valor for for
being killed in
action and they have not been given this
purple heart and it takes a
Congressional um action and all kinds of
efforts and petitions and lawsuits to
make this
happen the same year prior to the
November 2009 event the same year June
1st
2009 there was a very very tragic event
that occurred that was also Islamic
Jihad
terrorism a young boy a young boy named
Carlos
bledo who had been brought up in Memphis
Tennessee by his father Melvin who had a
small business in
Memphis you can imagine this is a a
black fellow very proud of the fact that
his son Carlos was going to school the
the State University in Tennessee in
Nashville very very proud that he had
reached that
point Carlos went to the school and
became
radicalized within the school they sent
him to
Yemen in Yemen he was further
radicalized and he was told that his job
was to come back to America and perform
an act of
jihad so he could prove himself so he
did come
back and he tried to kill a rabbi and
his family he wasn't successful with
that but he went to Little Rock
Arkansas and he went to a recruiting
station in Little Rock
Arkansas and there he
found a soldier an American soldier in
uniform not someone he knew just
somebody walking out of the recruiting
station his name name happened to be
Andy
long and he shot him and killed
him the fathers the fathers of these two
boys came together and
created a a testimony in front of the
homeland security committee and Charles
Jacobs of Americans for peace and
tolerance created this DVD losing our
son
losing our sons two boys were
lost one was killed because he was in
army
uniform the other is serving a life
sentence in
prison he's also lost so here we have
the two
fathers we have Melvin
bledo and we have darus
long they are
crusading to try to get their message
told that this is what's going on in
America today on our
campuses our children are being
radicalized they are being misled they
are being told that Islam is this
religion of peace and they are told
they're being woed and embraced and and
misled and it leads to these tragedies
now the
boys this Andy long who was killed is
entitled also to a purple heart cuz he
was killed in
action an action against him by
terrorists and the government refuses to
recognize it and they call this a drive
by
killing so you have a driveby killing
and you have workplace violence and you
have denial denial
denial and our people are getting killed
and they our children are getting
brainwashed and the situation is
deteriorating we know about eurabia we
read the stories of what's going on
throughout
Europe and and we know it's coming here
now as as Robert said and as this
gentleman said and as Pam keeps saying
and so many others say we
know that that uh if we keep speaking
about it we can and possibly wake up the
American people but right now we have a
small very very dedicated energetic
crowd but where are the rest of the
people how can we wake them up what will
it take to wake them up we have to
really work at all of this and get this
message out because we don't want
America to become islaman we do not want
to lose our freedoms we love being
Americans we love enjoying these very
special Liberties that we have and we
have to work to preserve them thank
[Music]
you Helen Helen thank you I told you
would not disappoint